The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
JOHN TSITSIKLIS: So today we're
going to finish with the
core material of this class.
That is the material that has to
do with probability theory
in general.
And then for the rest of the
semester we're going to look
at some special types of models,
talk about inference.
Well, there's also going to
be a small module of core
material coming later.
But today we're basically
finishing chapter four.
And what we're going to do is
we're going to look at a
somewhat familiar concept, the
concept of the conditional
expectation.
But we're going to look at it
from a slightly different
angle, from a slightly more
sophisticated angle.
And together with the
conditional expectation we
will also talk about conditional
variances.
It's something that we're going
to denote this way.
And we're going to see what they
are, and there are some
subtle concepts that
are involved here.
And we're going to apply some
of the tools we're going to
develop to deal with a special
type of situation in which
we're adding random variables.
But we're adding a random number
of random variables.
OK, so let's start talking
about conditional
expectations.
I guess you know
what they are.
Suppose we are in the discrete
the world. xy, or discrete
random variables.
We defined the conditional
expectation of x given that I
told you the value of the
random variable y.
And the way we define it is the
same way as an ordinary
expectation, except that we're
using the conditional PMF.
So we're using the probabilities
that apply to
the new universe where we are
told the value of the random
variable y.
So this is still a familiar
concept so far.
If we're dealing with the
continuous random variable x
the formula is the same, except
that here we have an
integral, and we have to use
the conditional density
function of x.
Now what I'm going to do, I want
to introduce it gently
through the example that we
talked about last time.
So last time we talked about
having a stick that has a
certain length.
And we take that stick, and we
break it at some point that we
choose uniformly at random.
And let's denote why the place
where we chose to break it.
Having chosen y, then
we're left with a
piece of the stick.
And I'm going to choose a place
to break it once more
uniformly at random
between 0 and y.
So this is the second place at
which we are going to break
it, and we call that place x.
OK, so what's the conditional
expectation of x if I tell you
the value of y?
I tell you that capital Y
happens to take a specific
numerical value.
So this capital Y is now a
specific numerical value, x is
chosen uniformly over
this range.
So the expected value of x is
going to be half of this range
between 0 and y.
So the conditional expectation
is little y over 2.
The important thing to realize
here is that this
quantity is a number.
I told you that the random
variable took a certain
numerical value,
let's say 3.5.
And then you tell me given that
the random variable took
the numerical value 3.5 the
expected value of x is 1.75.
So this is an equality
between numbers.
On the other hand, before you
do the experiment you don't
know what y is going
to turn out to be.
So this little y is the
numerical value that has been
observed when you start doing
the experiments and you
observe the value of capital
Y. So in some sense this
quantity is not known ahead of
time, it is random itself.
So maybe we can start thinking
of it as a random variable.
So to put it differently, before
we do the experiment I
ask you what's the expected
value of x given y?
You're going to answer me well
I don't know, it depends on
what y is going to
turn out to be.
So the expected value of x given
y itself can be viewed
as a random variable, because
it depends on the random
variable capital Y.
So hidden here there's some kind
of statement about random
variables instead of numbers.
And that statement about
random variables, we
write it this way.
By thinking of the expected
value, the conditional
expectation, as a random
variable instead of a number.
It's a random variable when we
do not specify a specific
number, but we think of it
as an abstract object.
The expected value of x given
the random variable y is the
random variable y over 2 no
matter what capital Y
turns out to be.
So we turn and take a statement
that deals with
equality of two numbers, and we
make it a statement that's
an equality between two
random variables.
OK so this is clearly a random
variable because
capital Y is random.
What exactly is this object?
I didn't yet define it
for you formally.
So let's now give the formal
definition of this object
that's going to be
denoted this way.
The conditional expectation of
x given the random variable y
is a random variable.
Which random variable is it?
It's the random variable that
takes this specific numerical
value whenever capital Y happens
to take the specific
numerical value little y.
In particular, this is a random
variable, which is a
function of the random variable
capital Y. In this
instance, it's given by a simple
formula in terms of
capital Y. In other situations
it might be a
more complicated formula.
So again, to summarize,
it's a random.
The conditional expectation can
be thought of as a random
variable instead of something
that's just a number.
So in any specific context when
you're given the value of
capital Y the conditional
expectation becomes a number.
This is the realized value
of this random variable.
But before the experiment
starts, before you know what
capital Y is going to be, all
that you can say is that the
conditional expectation is going
to be 1/2 of whatever
capital Y turns out to be.
This is a pretty subtle concept,
it's an abstraction,
but it's a useful abstraction.
And we're going to see
today how to use it.
All right, I have made the point
that the conditional
expectation, the random variable
that takes these
numerical values is
a random variable.
If it is a random variable
this means that it has an
expectation of its own.
So let's start thinking what
the expectation of the
conditional expectation is
going to turn out to be.
OK, so the conditional
expectation is a random
variable, and in general it's
some function of the random
variable y that we
are observing.
In terms of numerical values if
capital Y happens to take a
specific numerical value then
the conditional expectation
also takes a specific numerical
value, and we use
the same function
to evaluate it.
The difference here is that this
is an equality of random
variables, this is an equality
between numbers.
Now if we want to calculate
the expected value of the
conditional expectation we're
basically talking about the
expected value of a function
of a random variable.
And we know how to calculate
expected values of a function.
If we are in the discrete case,
for example, this would
be a sum over all y's of the
function who's expected value
we're taking times the
probability that y takes on a
specific numerical value.
OK, but let's remember
what g is.
So g is the numerical value
of the conditional
expectation of x with y.
And now when you see this
expression you recognize it.
This is the expression
that we get in the
total expectation theorem.
Did I miss something?
Yes, in the total expectation
theorem to find the expected
value of x, we divide the world
into different scenarios
depending on what y happens.
We calculate the expectation
in each one of the possible
worlds, and we take the
weighted average.
So this is a formula that you
have seen before, and you
recognize that this is the
expected value of x.
So this is a longer, more
detailed derivation of what I
had written up here, but the
important thing to keep in
mind is the moral of the
story, the punchline.
The expected value of the
conditional expectation is the
expectation itself.
So this is just our total
expectation theorem, but
written in more abstract
notation.
And it comes handy to have this
more abstract notation,
as as we're going to
see in a while.
OK, we can apply this to
our stick example.
If we want to find the expected
value of x how much
of the stick is left
at the end?
We can calculate it using this
law of iterated expectations.
It's the expected value of the
conditional expectation.
We know that the conditional
expectation is y over 2.
So expected value of y is l over
2, because y is uniform
so we get l over 4.
So this gives us the same answer
that we derived last
time in a rather long way.
All right, now that we have
mastered conditional
expectations, let's raise the
bar a little more and talk
about conditional variances.
So the conditional expectation
is the mean value, or the
expected value, in a conditional
universe where
you're told the value of y.
In that same conditional
universe you can talk about
the conditional distribution
of x, which has a mean--
the conditional expectation--
but the conditional
distribution of
x also has a variance.
So we can talk about the
variance of x in that
conditional universe.
The conditional variance as a
number is the natural thing.
It's the variance of x, except
that all the calculations are
done in the conditional
universe.
In the conditional universe the
expected value of x is the
conditional expectation.
This is the distance from the
mean in the conditional
universe squared.
And we take the average value
of the squared distance, but
calculate it again using the
probabilities that apply in
the conditional universe.
This is an equality
between numbers.
I tell you the value of y, once
you know that value for y
you can go ahead and plot the
conditional distribution of x.
And for that conditional
distribution you can calculate
the number which is the
variance of x in that
conditional universe.
So now let's repeat the mental
gymnastics from the previous
slide, and abstract things, and
define a random variable--
the conditional variance.
And it's going to be a random
variable because we leave the
numerical value of capital
Y unspecified.
So ahead of time we don't know
what capital Y is going to be,
and because of that we don't
know ahead of time what the
conditional variance
is going to be.
So before the experiment starts
if I ask you what's the
conditional variance of x?
You're going to tell me well I
don't know, It depends on what
y is going to turn out to be.
It's going to be something
that depends on y.
So it's a random variable,
which is a function of y.
So more precisely, the
conditional variance when
written in this notation just
with capital letters, is a
random variable.
It's a random variable whose
value is completely determined
once you learned the value of
capital Y. And it takes a
specific numerical value.
If capital Y happens to get a
realization that's a specific
number, then the variance also
becomes a specific number.
And it's just a conditional
variance of y
over x in that universe.
All right, OK, so let's continue
what we did in the
previous slide.
We had the law of iterated
expectations.
That told us that expected
value of a conditional
expectation is the unconditional
expectation.
Is there a similar rule that
might apply in this context?
So you might guess that the
variance of x could be found
by taking the expected value of
the conditional variance.
It turns out that this
is not true.
There is a formula for the
variance in terms of
conditional quantities.
But the formula is a little
more complicated.
If involves two terms
instead of one.
So we're going to go
quickly through the
derivation of this formula.
And then, through examples
we'll try to get some
interpretation of what the
different terms here
correspond to.
All right, so let's try
to prove this formula.
And the proof is sort of a
useful exercise to make sure
you understand all the symbols
that are involved in here.
So the proof is not difficult,
it's 4 and 1/2 lines of
algebra, of just writing
down formulas.
But the challenge is to make
sure that at each point you
understand what each one
of the objects is.
So we go into formula for
the variance affects.
We know in general that the
variance of x has this nice
expression that we often
use to calculate it.
The expected value of the
squared of the random variable
minus the mean squared.
This formula, for the variances,
of course it should
apply to conditional
universes.
I mean it's a general formula
about variances.
If we put ourselves in a
conditional universe where the
random variable y is given to us
the same math should work.
So we should have a similar
formula for
the conditional variances.
It's just the same formula,
but applied to
the conditional universe.
The variance of x in the
conditional universe is the
expected value of x squared--
in the conditional universe--
minus the mean of x-- in the
conditional universe--
squared.
So this formula looks fine.
Now let's take expected
values of both sides.
Remember the conditional
variance is a random variable,
because its value depends on
whatever realization we get
for capital Y. So we can
take expectations here.
We get the expected value
of the variance.
Then we have the expected
value of a conditional
expectation.
Here we use the fact that
we discussed before.
The expected value of a
conditional expectation is the
same as the unconditional
expectation.
So this term becomes this.
And finally, here we just have
some weird looking random
variable, and we take the
expected value of it.
All right, now we need to do
something about this term.
Let's use the same
rule up here to
write down this variance.
So variance of an expectation,
that's kind of strange, but
you remember that the
conditional expectation is
random, because y is random.
So this thing is a random
variable, so
this thing has a variance.
What is the variance
of this thing?
It's the expected value of the
thing squared minus the square
of the expected value
of the thing.
Now what's the expected
value of that thing?
By the law of iterated
expectations, once more, the
expected value of this thing
is the unconditional
expectation.
And that's why here I put the
unconditional expectation.
So I'm using again this general
rule about how to
calculate variances, and I'm
applying it to calculate the
variance of the conditional
expectation.
And now you notice that if you
add these two expressions c
and d we get this plus
that, which is this.
It's equal to--
these two terms cancel, we're
left with this minus that,
which is the variance of x.
And that's the end
of the proof.
This one of those proofs that
do not convey any intuition.
This, as I said, it's a useful
proof to go through just to
make sure you understand
the symbols.
It starts to get pretty
confusing, and a little bit on
the abstract side.
So it's good to understand
what's going on.
Now there is intuition behind
this formula, some of which is
better left for later
in the class when
we talk about inference.
The idea is that the conditional
expectation you
can interpret it as an estimate
of the random
variable that you
are trying to--
an estimate of x based on
measurements of y, you can
think of these variances as
having something to do with an
estimation error.
And once you start thinking in
those terms an interpretation
will come about.
But again as I said this is
better left for when we start
talking about inference.
Nevertheless, we're going to get
some intuition about all
these formulas by considering
a baby example where we're
going to apply the law of
iterated expectations, and the
law of total variance.
So the baby example is that we
do this beautiful experiment
of giving a quiz to a class
consisting of many sections.
And we're interested in
two random variables.
So we have a number of students,
and they're all
allocated to sections.
The experiment is that I pick
a student at random, and I
look at two random variables.
One is the quiz score of the
randomly selected student, and
the other random variable is
the section number of the
student that I have selected.
We're given some statistics
about the two sections.
Section one has 10 students,
section two has 20 students.
The quiz average in section
one was 90.
Quiz average in section
two was 60.
What's the expected
value of x?
What's the expected quiz score
if I pick a student at random?
Well, each student has the same
probability of being selected.
I'm making that assumption
out of the 30 students.
I need to add the quiz scores
of all of the students.
So I need to add the quiz scores
in section one, which
is 90 times 10.
I need to add the quiz scores
in that section,
which is 60 times 20.
And we find that the overall
average was 70.
So this is the usual
unconditional expectation.
Let's look at the conditional
expectation, and let's look at
the elementary version
where we're talking
about numerical values.
If I tell you that the randomly
selected student was
in section one what's the
expected value of the quiz
score of that student?
Well, given this information,
we're picking a random student
uniformly from that section in
which the average was 90.
The expected value of the
score of that student
is going to be 90.
So given the specific value of
y, the specific section, the
conditional expectation or the
expected value of the quiz
score is a specific number,
the number 90.
Similarly for the second section
the expected value is
60, that's the average score
in the second section.
This is the elementary
version.
What about the abstract
version?
In the abstract version the
conditional expectation is a
random variable because
it depends.
In which section is the
student that I picked?
And with probability 1/3, I'm
going to pick a student in the
first section, in which case
the conditional expectation
will be 90, and with probability
2/3 I'm going to
pick a student in the
second section.
And in that case the conditional
expectation will
take the value of 60.
So this illustrates the idea
that the conditional
expectation is a random
variable.
Depending on what y is going
to be, the conditional
expectation is going to be one
or the other value with
certain probabilities.
Now that we have the
distribution of the
conditional expectation
we can calculate the
expected value of it.
And the expected value of such a
random variable is 1/3 times
90, plus 2/3 times 60, and
it comes out to equal 70.
Which miraculously is the same
number that we got up there.
So this tells you that you can
calculate the overall average
in a large class by taking the
averages in each one of the
sections and weighing each one
of the sections according to
the number of students
that it has.
So this section had 90 students
but only 1/3 of the
students, so it gets
a weight of 1/3.
So the law of iterated
expectations, once more, is
nothing too complicated.
It's just that you can calculate
overall class
average by looking
at the section
averages and combine them.
Now since the conditional
expectation is a random
variable, of course it has
a variance of it's own.
So let's calculate
the variance.
How do we calculate variances?
We look at all the possible
numerical values of this
random variable, which
are 90 and 60.
We look at the difference of
those possible numerical
values from the mean of this
random variable, and the mean
of that random variable, we
found that's it's 70.
And then we weight the different
possible numerical
values according to their
probabilities.
So with probability 1/3 the
conditional expectation is 90,
which is 20 away
from the mean.
And we get this squared
distance.
With probability 2/3 the
conditional expectation is 60,
which is 10 away from the
mean, has this squared
distance and gets weighed
by 2/3, which is the
probability of 60.
So you do the numbers, and you
get the value for the variance
equal to 200.
All right, so now we want to
move towards using that more
complicated formula involving
the conditional variances.
OK, suppose someone goes and
calculates the variance of the
quiz scores inside each
one of the sections.
So someone gives us these two
pieces of information.
In section one we take the
differences from the mean in
that section, and let's say that
the various turns out to
be a number equal
to 10 similarly
in the second section.
So these are the variances
of the quiz scores inside
individual sections.
The variance in one conditional
universe, the
variance in the other
conditional universe.
So if I pick a student in
section one and I don't tell
you anything more about the
student, what's the variance
of the random score
of that student?
The variance is 10.
I know why, but I don't
know the student.
So the score is still a random
variable in that universe.
It has a variance, and
that's the variance.
Similarly, in the other
universe, the variance of the
quiz scores is this
number, 20.
Once more, this is an equality
between numbers.
I have fixed the specific
value of y.
So I put myself in a specific
universe, I can calculate the
variance in that specific
universe.
If I don't specify a numerical
value for capital Y, and say I
don't know what Y is going to
be, it's going to be random.
Then what kind of section
variance I'm going to get
itself will be random.
With probability 1/3, I pick a
student in the first section
in which case the conditional
variance given what I have
picked is going to be 10.
Or with probability 2/3 I pick
y equal to 2, and I place
myself in that universe.
And in that universe the
conditional variance is 20.
So you see again from here that
the conditional variance
is a random variable that takes
different values with
certain probabilities.
And which value it takes depends
on the realization of
the random variable capital Y.
So this happens if capital Y
is one, this happens if capital
Y is equal to 2.
Once you have something
of this form--
a random variable that takes
values with certain
probabilities--
then you can certainly calculate
the expected value
of that random variable.
Don't get intimidated by the
fact that this random
variable, it's something that's
described by a string
of eight symbols, or
seven, instead of
just a single letter.
Think of this whole string of
symbols there as just being a
random variable.
You could call it z for example,
use one letter.
So z is a random variable that
takes these two values with
these corresponding
probabilities.
So we can talk about the
expected value of Z, which is
going to be 1/3 times 10, 2/3
times 20, and we get a certain
number from here.
And now we have all the pieces
to calculate the overall
variance of x.
The formula from the previous
slide tells us this.
Do we have all the pieces?
The expected value of
the variance, we
just calculated it.
The variance of the expected
value, this was the last
calculation in the
previous slide.
We did get a number for
it, it was 200.
You add the two, you find
the total variance.
Now the useful piece of this
exercise is to try to
interpret these two numbers,
and see what they mean.
The variance of x given y for
a specific y is the variance
inside section one.
This is the variance
inside section two.
The expected value is some
kind of average of the
variances inside individual
sections.
So this term tells us
something about the
variability of this course,
how widely spread they are
within individual sections.
So we have three sections, and
this course happens to be--
OK, let's say the sections
are really different.
So here you have undergraduates
and here you
have post-doctoral students.
And these are the quiz scores,
that's section one, section
two, section three.
Here's the mean of the
first section.
And the variance has something
to do with the spread.
The variance in the second
section has something to do
with the spread, similarly
with the third spread.
And the expected value of the
conditional variances is some
weighted average of the three
variances that we get from
individual sections.
So variability within sections
definitely contributes
something to the overall
variability of this course.
But if you ask me about the
variability over the entire
class there's a second effect.
That has to do with the fact
that different sections are
very different from
each other.
That these courses here are far
away from those scores.
And this term is the one
that does the job.
This one looks at the expected
values inside each section,
and these expected values are
this, this, and that.
And asks a question how widely
spread are they?
It asks how different from
each other are the means
inside individual sections?
And in this picture it would be
a large number because the
difference section means
are quite different.
So the story that this formula
is telling us is that the
overall variability of the quiz
scores consists of two
factors that can be quantified
and added.
One factor is how much
variability is there inside
individual sections?
And the other factor is how
different are the sections
from each other?
Both effects contribute
to the overall
variability of this course.
Let's continue with just one
more numerical example.
Just to get the hang of doing
these kinds of calculations,
and apply this formula to do a
divide and conquer calculation
of the variance of a
random variable.
Just for variety now we're going
to take a continuous
random variable.
Somebody gives you a PDF if this
form, and they ask you
for the variance.
And you say oh that's too
complicated, I don't want to
do integrals.
Can I divide and conquer?
And you say OK, let me do
the following trick.
Let me define a random
variable, y.
Which takes the value 1 if x
falls in here, and takes the
value 2 if x falls in
the second interval.
And let me try to work in the
conditional world where things
might be easier, and then
add things up to
get the overall variance.
So I have defined y this
particular way.
In this example y becomes
a function of x.
y is completely determined
by x.
And I'm going to calculate the
overall variance by trying to
calculate all of the terms
that are involved here.
So let's start calculating.
First observation is that this
event has probability 1/3, and
this event has probability
2/3.
The expected value of x given
that we are in this universe
is 1/2, because we
have a uniform
distribution from 0 to 1.
Here we have a uniform
distribution from 1 to 2, so
the conditional expectation of
x in that universe is 3/2.
How about conditional
variances?
In the world who are y is equal
to 1 x has a uniform
distribution on a
unit interval.
What's the variance of x?
By now you've probably seen that
formula, it's 1 over 12.
1 over 12 is the variance of a
uniform distribution over a
unit interval.
When y is equal to 2 the
variance is again 1 over 12.
Because in this instance again
x has a uniform distribution
over an interval
of unit length.
What's the overall expected
value of x?
The way you find the overall
expected value is to consider
the different numerical values
of the conditional
expectation.
And weigh them according
to their probabilities.
So with probability 1/3
the conditional
expectation is 1/2.
And with probability
2/3 the conditional
expectation is 3 over 2.
And this turns out
to be 7 over 6.
So this is the advance work
we need to do, now let's
calculate a few things here.
What's the variance of the
expected value of x given y?
Expected value of x given y is
a random variable that takes
these two values with
these probabilities.
So to find the variance we
consider the probability that
the expected value takes the
numerical value of 1/2 minus
the mean of the conditional
expectation.
What's the mean of the
conditional expectation?
It's the unconditional
expectation.
So it's 7 over 6.
We just did that calculation.
So I'm putting here that number,
7 over 6 squared.
And then there's a second term
with probability 2/3, the
conditional expectation takes
this value of 3 over 2, which
is so much away from the mean,
and we get this contribution.
So this way we have calculated
the variance of the
conditional expectation,
this is this term.
What is this?
Any guesses what
this number is?
It's 1 over 12, why?
The conditional variance just
happened in this example to be
1 over 12 no matter what.
So the conditional variance
is a deterministic random
variable that takes
a constant value.
So the expected value of
this random variable
is just 1 over 12.
So we got the two pieces that we
need, and so we do have the
overall variance of the
random variable x.
So this was just an academic
example in order to get the
hang of how to manipulate
various quantities.
Now let's use what we have
learned and the tools that we
have to do something a little
more interesting.
OK, so by now you're all in
love with probabilities.
So over the weekend you're going
to bookstores to buy
probability books.
So you're going to visit a
random number bookstores, and
at each one of the bookstores
you're going to spend a random
amount of money.
So let n be the number of stores
that you are visiting.
So n is an integer--
non-negative random variable--
and perhaps you know
the distribution
of that random variable.
Each time that you walk into a
store your mind is clear from
whatever you did before, and you
just buy a random number
of books that has nothing to
do with how many books you
bought earlier on the day.
It has nothing to do with
how many stores you are
visiting, and so on.
So each time you enter as a
brand new person, and buy a
random number of books,
and spend a
random amount of money.
So what I'm saying, more
precisely, is that I'm making
the following assumptions.
That for each store i--
if you end up visiting
the i-th store--
the amount of money that you
spend is a random variable
that has a certain
distribution.
That distribution is the same
for each store, and the xi's
from store to store are
independent from each other.
And furthermore, the xi's are
all independent of n.
So how much I'm spending at the
store-- once I get in--
has nothing to do with how
many stores I'm visiting.
So this is the setting that
we're going to look at.
y is the total amount of money
that you did spend.
It's the sum of how much you
spent in the stores, but the
index goes up to capital N.
And what's the twist here?
It's that we're dealing with the
sum of independent random
variables except that how many
random variables we have is
not given to us ahead of time,
but it is chosen at random.
So it's a sum of a random number
of random variables.
We would like to calculate some
quantities that have to
do with y, in particular the
expected value of y, or the
variance of y.
How do we go about it?
OK, we know something about the
linearity of expectations.
That expectation of a sum is the
sum of the expectations.
But we have used that rule only
in the case where it's
the sum of a fixed number
of random variables.
So expected value of x plus y
plus z is expectation of x,
plus expectation of y, plus
expectation of z.
We know this for a fixed number
of random variables.
We don't know it, or how it
would work for the case of a
random number.
Well, if we know something
about the case for fixed
random variables let's transport
ourselves to a
conditional universe where the
number of random variables
we're summing is fixed.
So let's try to break the
problem divide and conquer by
conditioning on the different
possible values of the number
of bookstores that
we're visiting.
So let's work in the conditional
universe, find the
conditional expectation in this
universe, and then use
our law of iterated expectations
to see what
happens more generally.
If I told you that I visited
exactly little n stores, where
little n now is a number,
let's say 10.
Then the amount of money you're
spending is x1 plus x2
all the way up to x10 given
that we visited 10 stores.
So what I have done here is that
I've replaced the capital
N with little n, and I can do
this because I'm now in the
conditional universe
where I know that
capital N is little n.
Now little n is fixed.
We have assumed that n is
independent from the xi's.
So in this universe of a fixed
n this information here
doesn't tell me anything new
about the values of the x's.
If you're conditioning random
variables that are independent
from the random variables you
are interested in, the
conditioning has no effect,
and so it can be dropped.
So in this conditional universe
where you visit
exactly 10 stores the expected
amount of money you're
spending is the expectation of
the amount of money spent in
10 stores, which is the sum of
the expected amount of money
in each store.
Each one of these is the same
number, because the random
variables have identical
distributions.
So it's n times the expected
value of money you spent in a
typical store.
This is almost obvious without
doing it formally.
If I'm telling you that you're
visiting 10 stores, what you
expect to spend is 10 times the
amount you expect to spend
in each store individually.
Now let's take this equality
here and rewrite it in our
abstract notation, in terms
of random variables.
This is an equality
between numbers.
Expected value of y given that
you visit 10 stores is 10
times this particular number.
Let's translate it into
random variables.
In random variable notation,
the expected value of money
you're spending given the
number of stores--
but without telling you
a specific number--
is whatever that number of
stores turns out to be times
the expected value of x.
So this is a random variable
that takes this as a numerical
value whenever capital
N happens to be
equal to little n.
This is a random variable, which
by definition takes this
numerical value whenever
capital N is
equal to little n.
So no matter what capital N
happens to be what specific
value, little n, it takes
this is equal to that.
Therefore the value of this
random variable is going to be
equal to that random variable.
So as random variables, these
two random variables are equal
to each other.
And now we use the law of
iterated expectations.
The law of iterated expectations
tells us that the
overall expected value of y is
the expected value of the
conditional expectation.
We have a formula for the
It's n times expected
value of x.
Now the expected value
of x is a number.
Expected value of something
random times a number is
expected value of the
random variable
times the number itself.
We can take a number outside
the expectation.
So expected value of
x gets pulled out.
And that's the conclusion,
that overall the expected
amount of money you're going to
spend is equal to how many
stores you expect to visit on
the average, and how much
money you expect to spend on
each one on the average.
You might have guessed that
this is the answer.
If you expect to visit 10
stores, and you expect to
spend $100 on each store, then
yes, you expect to spend
$1,000 today.
You're not going to impress your
Harvard friends if you
tell them that story.
It's one of the cases where
reasoning, on the average,
does give you the plausible
answer.
But you will be able to impress
your Harvard friends
if you tell them that I can
actually calculate the
variance of how much
I can spend.
And we're going to work by
applying this formula that we
have, and the difficulty is
basically sorting out all
those terms here, and
what they mean.
So let's start with this term.
So the expected value of y given
that you're visiting n
stores is n times the
expected value of x.
That's what we did in
the previous slide.
So this thing is a random
variable, it has a variance.
What is the variance?
Is the variance of n times
the expected value of x.
Remember expected value
of x is a number.
So we're dealing with the
variance of n times a number.
What happens when you
multiply a random
variable by a constant?
The variance becomes the
previous variance times the
constant squared.
So the variance of this is the
variance of n times the square
of that constant that
we had here.
So this tells us the variance
of the expected
value of y given n.
This is the part of the
variability of how much money
you're spending, which is
attributed to the randomness,
or the variability, in
the number of stores
that you are visiting.
So the interpretation of the
two terms is there's
randomness in how much you're
going to spend, and this is
attributed to the randomness
in the number of stores
together with the randomness
inside individual stores.
Well, after I tell you how many
stores you're visiting.
So now let's deal with this
term-- the variance inside
individual stores.
Let's take it slow.
If I tell you that you're
visiting exactly little n
stores, then y is how much
money you spent in those
little n stores.
You're dealing with the sum of
little n random variables.
What is the variance
of the sum of
little n random variables?
It's the sum of their
variances.
So each store contributes a
variance of x, and you're
adding over little n stores.
That's the variance of money
spent if I tell you
the number of stores.
Now let's translate this into
random variable notation.
This is a random variable that
takes this numerical value
whenever capital N is
equal to little n.
This is a random variable that
takes this numerical value
whenever capital N is
equal to little n.
This is equal to that.
Therefore, these two are always
equal, no matter what
happens to y.
So we have an equality here
between random variables.
Now we take expectations
of both.
Expected value of the variance
is expected value of this.
OK it may look confusing to
think of the expected value of
the variance here, but the
variance of x is a number, not
a random variable.
You think of it as a constant.
So its expected value of n times
a constant gives us the
expected value of n times
the constant itself.
So now we got the second term
as well, and now we put
everything together, this plus
that to get an expression for
the overall variance of y.
Which again, as I said before,
the overall variability in y
has to do with the variability
of how much you spent inside
the typical store.
And the variability in
the number of stores
that you are visiting.
OK, so this is it for today.
We'll change subjects quite
radically from next time.